il bagno caldo è arrivato il momento di
tagliare staff arma che non so se vedete
un po incerto ma fatemi compagnia mentre
lo faccio oddio quel cade tutto perché
sono nel giusto perché io ti amo
ricominciamo
ma mamma dolce con sé dolce stasera mi
viene da noi a ricominciamo in attesa
della saga del signore degli anelli in
arrivo da domani su canale 5 credo 31 ho
preso l'ardua decisione di iniziare a
leggere il libro non l'ho mai fatto e
dunque è diva del momento di farlo sono
più di mille pagine mi sono ripromesso
chiaramente di arrivare in anticipo sui
film ovvero domani ci sarà la compagnia
dell'anello e quindi dovrò aver finito
almeno la compagnia dell'anello
poi fortunatamente ho scoperto che
saranno uno a settimana e quindi non
avrò problemi a finire il protone
arrivato un buon punto ho letto 400
pagine mi mancano pochi capitoli alla
fine della compagnia commesso abbastanza
bene secondo me vi faccio vedere come è
fatto questo libro perché questa
edizione è pazzesca questa è un'edizione
di mio fratello ha veramente bella il
tessuto e particolarissimo potrebbe
essere tipo scroto di drago una roba del
genere comunque aprendo lo abbiamo una
mappa zoomata della contea hobbiville
che dove stanno bilbo frode questi qua e
fa il suo viaggio verso break nel libro
questo tragitto durato dieci giorni e
gli hobbit si cagano sotto proprio in
questi dieci giorni durante il libro poi
ho capito che tv un botto tenere
d'occhio la mappa se no non ci capisce
una fava mentre alla fine di questo
eccezionale manuale di oltre mille
pagine ci sta questa fantastica mappa
vedete la contea abbiamo abbiamo gondor
abbiamo morde qua c'è il bosco atro
oppure questa mappa è un materiale
antichissimo secondo me è stata fatta
col blande di sauron
dunque vi sto dicendo ho letto 400
pagine sono quasi al termine della
compagnia dell'anello a settimana dopo
faranno le due torri ma io mi auguro
averlo finito entrano le due torri il
libro e niente queste sono le mie
letture male
thiene
meglio sia così che di luca parate di
spalle come sto meglio con questa barba
e ciò che sei
inoltre vi farò vedere tre elementi che
dimostrano quanto in questa famiglia
siamo malati per questa saga partiamo
col primo segnale di aragorn che nome
abruzzo normale di aragorn bellissimo
prezzo di questo acquisto non 20 25 20
25 euro
poi questo è un pezzo forte en du reel
la spada forgiata dai frammenti fra di
nars il e la spada che sconfisse
l'oscuro signore e gli tagliò la mano
con l'anello al dito conto pure lì si
ridurrà da compiere questo eroico gesto
ribattezzata en du reel da aragorn
figlio di herat ora un prezzo di questo
articolo live agata welfare e infine non
poteva mancare del potere questi erano i
tre oggetti ragazzi adesso posso tornare
alla lettura
addio ecco qua ho preparato un humus
greco alle olive
poi si dice che il supporto a cucinare
depuratore sono pronti finalmente
sfornati quadrotti equo la magia
costituito provate la mia ricetta
ragazzi è certo doveva avere una mano
abile con la cucina non è facilissima ma
perché non hai mai visto come ti faccio
il pesce in scatola io no ecco qua via
ecco qual pesce in scatola alla c'è
frigo veloce leggero gustoso succoso un
tenero
e per concludere il passo ragazzo appena
finito un dolce fantastico con il nostro
microonde che è rotto da non so quanto
tempo abbiamo un po che cosa c'è qui
dentro
niente più
mi sento come barbie dopo l'abitazione
panettiera e l'abitazione paul veyne
serale che cosa accettata cooking lab di
adesso sto scoprendo una nuova cosa
siete pronti eccolo qui la b certi fa di
bricolage è il risultato dopo la prima
mano vecchio servo delle mie brame dimmi
chi è la più bella del reame
spiega bene stiamo mettendo in piedi
l'intro di una punto decisivo del
compeed è così amico più che amano la
marca dividendi no no no era fermo
appena dice uno di ripartire con le mani
e così che un wiki che è la nostra
questo essere io a sé è molto semplice
carichi di debito pubblico pesio le mani
con due tre quattro cinque sensi no 127
bravissimo bravissima
una mattinata giosa e il primo libro del
signore di rally pollice al suo termine
una missione è compiuta a una settimana
per leggere mi come minimo tutto le due
torri in sette giorni potrei uscire a
finire i ritmi dunque lo scopriremo nel
prossimo blog di ragazzi scusate ragazzi
ma senti in dovere di dovermi dare la
mia testimonianza ma guglielmo non ho
trovato bello perché compra tutto e
crema alla nocciola non solo venerdì 17
anno bisesto anno funesto giorno di
anemia la mia furia omicida verso questa
sofferta orribile verso il bricolage sta
acquisendo veramente livelli importanti
preoccupanti è il termine giusto
sto cominciando a scartavetrare invece
un mobiletto che era sempre buttato
lattico rigattiere nella mia cantina
nella desolazione post industriale ed
eccoci qua sta in parte del mio lavoro
chiederei a tutti di togliermi dalla
quarantena per il semplice fatto che al
trentino todi giungerò il mondo e bianco
allora è successo nella sua sorda non so
come filtro allenamento fisico rakovic
mi citofono di cono gelato
vi faccio curare scusino sbagliato
indirizzo e non ordinato il gelato non
so chi non so come mi è arrivato del
gelato il gelato tentatore mai nome fu
più appropriato non mi tiro fuori
non so proprio come sia possibile
un fan tutto coni tutto quanto un
ammiratore segreto forse stacco allora è
bello dei mama di aiuto il giorno che ti
ho mandato stracciatella e pistacchio mi
conoscono
il mistero si infittisce sempre di più è
proprio da fare ragazzi la panna romana
borsa se ormai mi sa che la fanno gli
altri posti e una bomba perché non è
zuccherata buonissima 20 facciamo
comunque un cono leggero e piana come
minimo quest'area fatica forza posso
fare tutto perché ho appena scoperto una
verità terribile beatrice ha il coraggio
di ripetere quello che mi hai appena
confessato
ripeti stasera tu hai appena mandato
tutto il mio piano in fumo con questa
esclamazione nei livelli la lakers e
vieni con me tu mi stai dicendo che al
posto della compagnia dell'anello a per
essere trasmesso quel pd metri ma vado a
guardare le tue ultime parole
ma tardi del prossimo episodio non sono
bravissimo a tagliare i capelli ci hanno
bacheca una macchinetta non penso dei
fatti sa che danno è però